let's bring in John Harper John Harper's
been covering Major League Baseball band
covering the Mets of 25 years now New
York Daily News columnist John thanks
for joining us on short notice
your thoughts on the possibility of the
Mets bringing up Tim Tebow this year in
September yeah I mean and I would I
would have had a major problem in Sandy
Alderson had said probably he's gonna be
a major league level at some point I
would add a major problem with it if the
Mets were still in a legitimate race at
the time but it doesn't look like
they're gonna be and obviously they're
not gonna be in a race so she's and lost
already so in that case I really
wouldn't have a major issue with it the
guy has shown me a lot by just sticking
it out demise I didn't think he'd stick
it out more than a year for sure riding
the buses in there in Binghamton and
Eastern League it's not a glamorous life
so I give him credit for that he's not
really considered a major league
prospect at 30 years old with a 727
o-p-s and limited power but he is he is
earning his way on a daily basis and
getting better why could see in
September but I was curious about now
John as bad as the Mets are and you know
let's face it people if you said Tebow
was playing tomorrow night I would watch
the game and I'm sure that if you know
the Mets and I don't know if it's a way
of saying hey but look over here we're
bad but we got Tim Tebow up here is that
something you think the Mets would be
willing to entertain I say that I think
they'd be leery about it from a PR
standpoint they know it would look bad
an inch and you can kind of shine even
more light on how how weak their foreign
system is and how few prospects they
actually have which is why you know they
can play Tebow in double-a nobody really
serving because they're not holding
anybody back by doing that their farm
system is a major issue for them there
they look like they're headed for you
know some tough times here I think they
need to have at least a limited rebuild
and trade a cinder guard it's not a
degrom but I don't I don't know if
they'll do that just because I think
they'd be worried about the PR they'll
take a hit for it and I think they know
that they can bring them up in September
and maybe get fans here at this point I
don't think they're thinking that way
but you never know with this what about
trade possibilities Jacob degrom keep
hearing that name the possibility that
the Mets are sellers here coming up yeah
I don't think they're gonna trade the
ground they're gonna mainly because they
was they're gonna set the bar so high
and anything they asked for from you
know talking to people around baseball
they would want say you know not today
whatever trade him of the Yankees
because they'd be so worried about him
winning World Championships there but
they would want say Glaber Torres and
about three of the other Yankees top
prospects and that's not happening but I
do think there's a possibility they
would trade syndergaard who's younger
than degrom and that's the way I would
go I think degrom has reached a level
such a high level and it's too bad the
Mets can't score for him he's in that
siyoung race with Scherzer one of the
best pitchers in baseball he's got that
he's a real athletic kid he played
shortstop in college before he got a
cool time pitching Lou slim delivery I
think he can pitch well into his mid-30s
and he just turned 30 syndergaard
younger but I would look to trade him
because I think you could get a haul for
him in terms of prospects and that's
what they need if they're gonna reset
this thing and put this thing back in
order in the next couple of years
I love degrom he's another one of those
guys that when I tuned in to watch and
he's on the mound like I'll stay because
I just I love I love his approach it's
like Scherzer these guys who just get up
there and bring it and you know that
it's not fancy it's just they're
bringing it and I'd hate to see them
trade him but you know every game it
feels like he pitches great and there's
no offensive support there for him at
all yeah I was there last night eight
scoreless innings he was great again
against the Phillies and you just I mean
the Mets offense is disaster to put that
line up they're putting out there is an
abomination they got a kid hitting 393
in Vegas and triple-a this kid McNeil
might be kind of a late bloomer he's not
even a kid he's 26 and yet they continue
to play Jose Reyes
now with Frazier on the DL at third base
rays hitting 168 for the season it's too
bad because degrom deserves better
he should have 12 13 wins at this point
he's five on four which I kind of wrote
about it really raises an interesting
question of
just how you know orders obviously have
looked at it differently now winds don't
count for nearly as much the guy with
the lowest total
Wintel everyone siyoung was Felix
Hernandez I think was 2010 with 13 wins
how low voters no I mean nine wins would
they go for nine wins if he's got the
best numbers I'm sure he's probably
gonna be right there with him so it's
really going to be interesting to see
this kind of would be a it might be a
record-setting type of vote I have to
look at the other candidates John if I
look back to Felix Hernandez who was the
other candidate and how many wins did
did he have was the second on the list
did somebody even have 20 wins 18 wins
back then yeah I think obviously some
people had more wins but that was kind
of the air is right that was kind of the
turning the turning point where voters
were starting to look at them with the
other numbers realized you know wins
really are so dependent on run support
and in the grounds case run support and
a bad bullpen that you do I mean I think
wins should still be considered
especially for two guys that are close
with all the other numbers and
Scherzer's I think he's got 11 wins now
he's probably gonna end up with more
wins but if after all the other numbers
are in the groms favor you know that's
gonna be really interesting talking to
John Harper New York Daily News
columnist Manny Machado I find it
interesting with the Yankees who do have
a great prospected third you got Dede
edge short and they might be in the
running or headlining everybody for
Manny Machado what do you think the the
odds are in these sweepstakes yeah I
just I did a compost in the odds and I
had the Dodgers Brewers and Diamondbacks
is lower or better odds they're getting
them but it does sound like the Yankees
I thought this was Cashman kind of doing
his usual thing he always is in on the
big guys just in case like Stanton in
the case of Stan Stan kind of fell in
their lap they didn't have to give up
hardly anything this is different
because I think they're gonna have to
give up something significant and you
know they love this kid Andujar they
probably have to they're good I mean I
if they get Machado they're gonna have
him play third base not shortstop even
if that's not what he wants I just it
doesn't make a lot of sense because they
really need a picture I know there's not
a great picture out there I mean you
know not counting the grammar
syndergaard they're getting him JJ HAP
you know Cole Hamels those kind of guys
so maybe they're I've heard that you
know Cashman thinks maybe they by adding
Machado the defense and offense he
brings we're giving them an edge in that
race with the Red Sox because they're so
desperate to stay out of that wild-card
game by winning the AL East but it's
still kind of it's still kind of strange
to me if they're gonna give up a big
package when they could just wait and
sign him in the offseason
I still have to kind of see it to
believe it I've been talking about Chris
Sale he's another one of those guys
there's certain guys like seven pitchers
it feels like when I'm flipping through
and and sale was on the mound last night
I mean it's remarkable John when you see
the disparity and he can throw an 81
mile an hour breaking ball and then he
can throw 99 and and he paints corners I
mean he's he's fearless too but he looks
like he weighs it you know buck 60 out
there pretty man and that's what's so
tough on especially lefties he's just
coming at you from the first base so
yeah it looks like sometimes and you're
right he is but all these guys you said
is so much fun to watch one thing about
and they all work quick yeah thank you I
mean their teammates love that and yeah
this guy I mean he chose that yeah he
throws upper-90s but then he throws that
slider on to the back foot of
right-handed hitters and they can't even
it looks like they've never seen it
before he is he's he's one of the best
and he deserves to win I saw one of
these years as well well he was you know
in relative obscurity there for seven
years with Chicago and if you don't play
in the postseason how much do you think
how much is factored in for pitchers
with postseason performance we talk
about hitters but when it comes to the
Hall of Fame how much do we rely on that
with pitchers young yeah I mean to me
MVP voting is difference I envy people
yeah I think doesn't matter if you're a
contender but siyoung has always been
who's the best just trying to figure out
who had the best year as a pitcher and I
think it does count for Hall of Fame
though I mean to me a guy like surely
should be in largely because of what he
did in the postseason those especially
for a pitcher
those are the biggest games they can
control those games if they're great and
Schilling has done that as well as
anybody
maybe his off-field stuff has heard him
in some ways I think that like that that
should really count for a lot I think
postseason for pitchers should really
matter but John why does it matter
Schilling political beliefs I don't
think it does I I would vote for him I
know but I know some people have said
especially you know remember the comment
he made about the journalists in the
Greek I think he he liked something that
t-shirt somebody hanging I mean that you
can't take that stuff personally though
if you're if you're a fuller you have to
be above that you have to separate
yourself now that to me that's a
separate issue from the PE D stuff I
don't vote for bonds or Clemens the peds
but Schilling that's just an off the
field that's that's a personal thing I
would never let that get in the way of a
vote
why isn't Sosa you know in strong
consideration for the Hall of Fame with
with no positive tests on record correct
yeah no positive tests but I think
there's enough circumstantial evidence
there and I think you know as a folder
it's not a court of law to me I can make
up my mind
how strongly I feel about guys and if
that matters there's nothing really
there's no test or anything to tie bonds
and Clemens to that yeah I believe I'm
hundred percent sure they did it I'm
almost 100% sure so she did it just
based on watching his career over the
years so I think that's the reason for
that and it's still fascinating but I I
view this younger group of baseball
writers it feels like they have a
different impression different opinion
than some of us older folks John yeah I
know the older guys are getting weed
it's yeah it's definitely changing and
the younger guy you're right the younger
guys and a lot of those guys that are
now voting and you have to have a bbw a
court for ten years to vote weren't
there during all this stuff and I think
they do have a different feel about it
they look at it differently it kind of
you know the feeling is a couple of
things you they were all doing it or
well I'm not going to be the judge and
jury decide who was doing it and who
wasn't when we're really not sure and I
with that to some extent but if I feel
strongly about God you were doing it I
just think I don't believe everybody was
doing it first of all so I think a lot
of guys did get cheated along the way so
that's my stance on it but I do and I
did end up voting for guys like Piazza
and Bagwell because if I'm not sure I
don't feel like you can tie them that
honor to me it is the highest honor in
the game and if I'm sure about a Barnes
and Clinton's I'm just not going to
reward them with that honor and I know
people make your own well basically the
whole here is a museum but their their
stuff is in the Hall of Fame they're
just not you started the plaque so
that's why I stand there John good stuff
thanks for joining us we appreciate your
time okay that's John Harper New York
Daily News columnist for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]